for the sake of my son put down your
sword I will not you are a fool
in 1543 three portuguese traders reached
Japan the first Europeans to ever set
foot on its shore they were of course
from the West but since they arrived at
the southern port from across southern
seas they were regarded as southern
barbarians in their wares were silk
porcelain but most importantly
Portuguese guns the Japan was in the
midst of a brutal civil war and a weapon
like this could turn the tide so
Japanese Smith's quickly reverse
engineered the weaponry and renewed
warfare swept throughout the country in
response many Smith's started to acquire
and experiment with European plate as
well as a result samurai armor became
stiffer but bullet resistant a
compromise with Western plate which was
impenetrable but cumbersome your sword
cannot pierce my armor why do you not
understand the armored Knight and his
son Robert likely stepped ashore during
this turbulent time making a name for
themselves by selling bright red
firecrackers their deafening sound could
be used to terrify beasts and unseen
horsemen which was a popular tool that
Robert and his father quickly turned
into local currency however the money
that they raised was not their goal it
was simply a means to an end for the
Knights son Robert was very sick and his
father needed to raise funds for their
travels across the sea he'd heard tales
of the undying in the mountains and as
soon as he sold off their wares they
headed for Mount Congo
whatever the sickness was that his son
had it was clearly worth risking
everything for as they were traveling
deep into warring States territory and
they would be lucky to survive strike me
all you like I am unbreakable my son
would receive the waters what he found
must have been beyond his wildest
imagination simple a powerful
institution of warrior monks who would
have just begun to close their doors to
the outside around this time they
believed they could attain eternal life
by experimenting with the legendary
waters that flowed through the lands of
the ocean ah this legend is so similar
to that of the Fountain of Youth
something that the armored Knight no
doubt believed could restore Robert to
good health have strength from Buddhist
teachers they have abandoned their faith
seduced by a search for immortality to
the monks however such a search for
immortality lay perfectly in line with
their own beliefs the ultimate goal of
the Buddha after all is liberation from
samsara the cycle of rebirth and if
these men could achieve eternal life
then they too may achieve enlightenment
just like the Buddha once did and the
secret they believed lay in the birth of
a divine child so they cut ties with the
ocean shut their doors and set to work
the gates to that temple are closed now
though who knows what those degenerates
are doing shut away up there in the
mountains first they needed children
hundreds of children children who would
be sacrificed for the monks greater good
this of course would bring incredible
negative karma in the next life
but what threat could negative karma
pose to the undying
so they grimly pressed ahead sacrificing
children but also laying tributes for
their departed souls small statues mibu
balloons and pinwheels that blow gently
in the wind the spinning spinning red
and white flowers only one pure white
flower the pure white flower I cannot
find when the ammonite arrived
the monks probably couldn't believe
their luck here was a man not only
willing to put his child into their care
but he was also willing to defend their
home he was a foreigner too one who
likely wouldn't guess at the meaning of
the little statues and pinwheels before
the bridge so they likely offered him a
deal repel a thousand blades and we will
grant your child the blessing of
rejuvenation of course the monks
probably did try to grant the blessing
of rejuvenation they might not have lied
to him completely but it is unlikely
that the armored Knight ever knew the
true meaning of the little statues of
the pinwheels as well nor is it likely
that he discovered the bound bodies
hurled off the cliff behind him he would
never have a chance to but he would go
on to join them not at the hands of the
monks but by the boot of a shinobi who
needed to pass
thinking he'd failed his son
but what he would never know was that a
child of the rejuvenating waters had
been successfully created long ago and
it could not have been Robert for of all
the pinwheels there is only one pure
white flower the divine child of the
rejuvenating waters if you watch this
video the week that it came out then the
next episode is actually already out and
you can watch it right now it's just
over on patreon I have a bunch of reward
tears over there but I think that giving
early access is probably my favorite one
because it allows me to sort of demo my
videos to a small dedicated audience and
then also reward those people for
helping to keep the channel going so if
you love from software's games go and
check it out
but of course whether you're a patron or
not you'll get to see the video very
soon and thank you for watching
[Music]